a lot of people watch TV all day I'd
rather play video games I say hours a
week my bigger issue just besides the
time of spending a lot of money for
spending and gambling in the games
I can't condemn the game for wanting to
be addictive because that's kind of the
point
[Music]
I'm amicable Dean and I've been looking
into the dark side of tech from facial
recognition to fake news I wanted to
understand how companies design
addictive games that maximize profit the
global market for games grew from
seventy billion dollars in 2012 to 122
billion in 2017
by comparison global box office revenue
for films in 2017 was forty 1 billion
dollars in America in the world and I
don't know where to focus and where to
look gaming has gotten so big that
watching others play attracts massive
crowds and two-thirds of American
households now play video games
according to the Entertainment Software
Association you play a lot again so yes
not as much as they used to why the how
how much would you when you were playing
a lot of games like
say like 30 hours a week at most
yeah I know right why do you play still
the aperture how let me say at least 50
hours a week it's on my free time all
your free time yeah
then set up Evans it tough do you ever
like lose track of time
some games can happily kind of let you
would make you lose track of time more
than others but it's definitely a
partner at the balanced kind of work
life personal life in video games I kind
of cut out the personal life part
focused more on the video game sparingly
do you ever feel it digs into these
games or one game in particular
like I understand like some games like
you don't make me like really upset okay
one study estimated that 9% of teen
gamers are addicted with an estimated
2.6 billion people playing video games
globally it's not a limited issue after
I heard that the World Health
Organization was classifying gaming
disorder as a mental health condition
this month my reporting brought me to
gaming rehab near Seattle you spent
eight weeks yeah I was playing on
average between like 12 to 16 hours a
day that would just be I would either be
playing video games watching porn
watching some show or I'll be sleeping
it every day yeah Jon Jones is in Phase
two of the program living in an
apartment provided by restart but free
to roam the real world a flip phone to
start out with and no computer users
would only be at corporate in the
computer lab my main excuse of
rationalizing was like I'm only playing
so much just because I'm because I'm
depressed and that's why like if I
wasn't oppressed I would be playing do
you think games are designed to be
addictive yeah and even like wow you
didn't even hesitate
Hillary Cash founded restart after
seeing patterns related to gaming and
screen addiction my first case was in
1994 and you know throughout the 90s you
know people were coming in for therapy
parents are handing their devices to
their kids and it's gonna really impact
their development and and prime them for
addiction even if they're not addicted
they're gonna be primed for it so I
think it is a growing problem the
initial seven weeks of Resident Care at
restart cost nearly $30,000 but Charlie
Brockie
said it changed his life did you feel
anxious shaky very much so there's very
very real physical withdrawal symptoms
to video gaming how serious a problem is
this I was so depressed that I started
researching how to kill myself on my
phone because I couldn't get up and go
to the computer to do so there are
concerns about the effective games on
kids
since nearly half of gamers are on
18 and mostly male and teens who spent
five hours a day gaming our 71% more
likely to be at risk for suicide than
those who spend less than one it just
kind of spiraled out of control until I
was gaming 16 hours a day there are a
few screen rehabs and experts are
divided on the best routes to health
though at restart a complete digital
detox is required I don't play games at
all if it's digital and gaming I don't
touch it and so I don't even know why
myself like pseudo ku on my phone
gaming used to be all about personal
computers and consoles you'd buy a game
outright and play it then smartphones
came along the gaming industry went to
what's called free-to-play which
basically you get the game and you can
play the game that's Bill Grasso a
gaming industry insider who founded
scientific revenue to help companies
maximize payments within their games if
you think about what a really bad game
is it's like the game that is completely
non addictive
designing a good game is inherently
trying to design something that people
want will want to come back to will feel
compelled to come back to it's also
helpful for making more money as games
transition to free-to-play the selling
of virtual goods became crucial by 2016
Grand Theft Auto 5 had sold more than 60
million copies but the free version GTA
online made more than 500 million
dollars on in-game microtransactions my
bigger issue just besides the time and
spending a lot of money they're spending
and gambling in the games
I will joke about it in the games like
oh really I oh yeah I just spent $600
yeah they're getting their money they're
ripping us off but we would we would
joke about how they they designed the
games to get you to play longer or get
you to spend more money now I get to pay
too much money to open loop boxes loot
boxes amount to a randomized purchase
that may or may not contain what you're
looking for
it's very definitely the same thing as a
roulette wheel but it's and it's very
definitely aimed at sort of the
compulsion and addiction side of the
game of the human personality I think
whoot boxes are straight-up gambling
it's something that keeps people coming
back keeps people grinding in the game
playing it longer and longer and because
you can't just buy what it is you want
you have to keep forking money over last
year
one game company caught so much flack
for the practice that they've advertised
a game this year with a simple message
no Lube boxes Belgium declared Lube box
as illegal gambling in April and
American politicians like senator Maggie
Hassan have also questioned the practice
do you agree that children being
addicted to gaming and activities like
loot boxes that might make them more
susceptible to addiction is a problem
that merits our attention so it'll be
like 300 400 and then it's like okay
well I'll keep going until I get it and
like if I don't get it
after a couple hundred dollars then I I
would get like really depressed and
sometimes I would just keep going I
already spent four hundred well I'm just
gonna spend until I until I get it loot
boxes are also one of the best ways to
bleed whales dry what is a whale so well
as industry terminology for someone who
spends too much fundamentally it's one
of those really unfortunate things in
that it's really a piece of terminology
that comes from Las Vegas well was
casino terminology for really really big
spender bill Grasso caught flak last
year because as his website brags his
company works to turn free users into
paid ones and keep more whales but
during our interview Grosso walked that
claim back if you look at some of the
coverage of scientific revenue where
people have said you know while they
spot whales and then milk them at the
psychologically maximal moment it's
there's no none whatsoever we're not
that good the claim remains on their
website and game companies remain
focused on whales o spend 10 20 30 grand
they're the people who keep the game
alive because they spend so much money
right yeah you wouldn't call yourself a
whale no because I was more like it low
good I did spend a lot with like 8 grand
in a year and that's a lot of money
of course it's not just games the reward
systems built into games are also built
into our phones and no method is off the
table
in the battle for our attention my name
is near Al and I'm the author of a book
called hooked how to build habit-forming
products near told me how to use
gamification and psychology to make apps
that will keep people coming back so
every hook starts with a trigger a
trigger is something in our environment
that tells us what to do next
paying a ding a ring some kind of
notification that tells us what to do
then the next step is the variable
reward it's some kind of uncertain
outcome that that that we're looking for
right so scrolling the feed has this
variable reward mechanism just like
pulling on a slot machine and then
finally the investment phase where we
put something into the product like data
followers content reputation that makes
the product better and better with use
eventually we're using the product
because of an internal trigger when
we're lonely we check Facebook when
we're uncertain we check Google when
we're bored we might check the news we
might check stock prices or sports
scores to satiate that need three out of
four American children have access to a
smartphone and nearly half of American
parents believe their kids are addicted
to mobile devices for now both gaming
companies and rehabs will profit while
gaming addicts are left with few
resources for recovery there's lots of
evidence to support that contact with
nature is actually very healing and
reduces anxiety reduce you know helps
people concentrate so we we have them
out in nature quite a lot what was your
favorite part of being here like
physically yeah trying to diversify
because just not get caught up in like
one thing and focus on that yeah I did
like most of the time was either spent
either with music I started playing
piano here Saturdays we'll just go out
walk through there go on hikes or do
different game
it's like outdoor games I think a big
part of it has been actually working on
the past stuff and actually like being
open and vulnerable and talking about
emotions and just recognizing my
emotions and just kind of being able to
deal with them more but also just the I
guess just that sense of kind of being a
little sad about how much time has been
wasted
hey it's Ahmed thanks for watching and
don't forget to watch the other videos
in this series including stories about
facial recognition and fake news and
don't forget to subscribe to AJ plus
[Music]